see you talked
you're friends with uh michael malus
he believes and so i want to kind of ask
you about government
uh he believes he's an anarchist yeah
and he believes kind of
in freedom fully implemented
in in human societies
meaning that humans should
all be free to choose how they
um you know transact with each other how
they live together
there shouldn't be a centralized force
that tells you what to do
do you think there's some role for
government
in um in a healthy society yeah so you
if we look at north korea there's the
most horrible implementation
of government but then if we
look at what the united states strives
to be at least
in principle there's uh there's an ideal
of a government that represents the
people and helps the people like is
there is there a place for that kind of
ideal
or is government always going to get us
into trouble i
am not i mean i spoke to michael males i
kept asking
why he's anarchist right and he doesn't
believe in military none of it happening
and it's i was like i was like i don't
think i want to be in the world
you're describing that's pretty scary i
want the law enforcement
i won't like i don't
in a way that so why equality makes no
sense is that
the fact that when you and i were born
we were born in a very different
capability of thinking
different intelligence different
capability in our physics right
so equality is nonsense you can never
achieve that
all right so to me that's been it's very
scary
when the government tries to introduce
equality on everybody that is
impossible that's specifically equality
of outcomes so like
so given that we all start different
places enforce
like measure in some kind of way where
people stand and if they're on equal
enforce equality
yeah and that's what leads to the kind
of things you mentioned with the class
system
right in north korea yeah so i think
that's why
government can be bad they can be very
dumb and
another another thing is that they
cannot know what you want a lot of times
people don't even know what they want
that
individual like how the heck do you
assume government gonna know what is
best for you
nobody knows we just all do our best
i do think though some governments
against switzerland
you know have more power give power to
the different state
can be good i think i'm more you know
like giving power to the state
and let individuals decide where they
want to go in within states like
i mean why did you choose taxes right
there's no
income tax right like there's a lot of
things people find texas
like you know charming and they come
here so in a way that
i don't want to be in a one strong
government it
makes every single thing the same way in
a way i want to kind of experiment
everything you can have anarchy state
there's no police nothing going on you
can be
whatever one you want and you can go on
stage
it's like abortion is bad blah blah this
is bad
all those conservative values and let
the ideas compete
and let them how they are being tracked
in real real life
but i think it's very scary when the
youth government is getting bigger and
bigger and then they try
to you know make every state under one
big government
and that's like when i get really
alarmed
you